(upbeat music)
- I can bench press 445 pounds.
I can flip a 270 pound tire.
I can do handstand push
ups, and I can climb a rope.
And I can look damned good doing it.
(upbeat music)
I'm Zack Ruhl, an adaptive
crossfitter and a powerlifter.
I was born with a deformity,
and pretty much my legs
looked real messed up,
so I would never be able to walk
using them so they made a decision
to get them amputated.
I've been an amputee, a double amputee,
since I was two years old.
(peaceful music)
My relationship with fitness
started out in high school.
I just started lifting
weights like anybody else,
and I always did it for
appearance at first.
If I'm just going to be a torso,
I'm going to be one
damn looking good torso.
And then it just took over my life.
Like, I wanted to know
everything there is to know
about the anatomy, the human body,
how to get stronger, what
creates muscle growth.
Like, I was a sponge.
I've been told I can't bench
press more than 400 pounds.
My ass.
I've been told I wouldn't
have a gym of my own.
My biggest motivation in life is people
telling me I can't do something.
(rock music)
I offer free classes or
free personal training
to adaptive athletes or
people with disabilities,
so, I have a girl with cerebral palsy,
I have a girl that has
a spinal cord injury,
and I have another quadruple amputee
that I'm personal training right now.
Crossfit has done so much for my life,
and I feel like I just
want to pass that on,
and show everybody that it is possible,
you can work past disabilities,
and whatever your goals are,
especially fitness-wise,
you can meet them,
it's just going to be a
little bit different route
than somebody else.
(rock music)